well I saw last night in Los Angeles and  I'd seen it you know several weeks  before and my ranch and you know it's  more fun to see it with a crowd  obviously but I had a great time there's  that thumbs up huh it's a thumbs up yeah  this is it's the interesting part is  we've we'd never done a premiere in the  United States we did a little small  premieres with charities but England is  the only place I've actually gotten real  premieres you know but usually we do  them for the princes charity because  it's to me so but I'm used to always  having the premier here in England good  somewhere they're made and the actual  film  give us your review what did you think  of it I can't review the film I think  the fans will love it you know and it's  getting good reviews to these franchises  somebody I had the I had the part was I  knew that so I made the decision and I  took my money off the table and now I'm  building museums and raising a daughter  and making my own little movies